yo les voy aquí cualquiera que sea la
noticia que reciba hoy haz que la reciba
con una actitud firme sabiendo que esto
santa voluntad lamentó ya se acabó la
año
alec es un pastor protestante y un
combatiente voluntario está preparando
esta unidad para la batalla
estos chicos van a firmar su contrato de
defensa territorial van a defender que
la mayoría de ellos no tienen
experiencia así que nuestro objetivo es
entrenarlos eso es lo que hemos estado
haciendo en las últimas dos semanas
entrenar a los chicos preparándonos para
ir al frente
estos nuevos reclutas están a punto de
alistarse durante tres años muchos de
ellos empuñan un fusil de asalto por
primera vez las unidades de defensa
territorial forman parte oficialmente de
las fuerzas armadas de ucrania pero
tienen su propia cadena de mando
como todos los comandantes de esta
unidad es miembro de la organización de
nacionalistas ucranianos uno
para mí
es una fuerza creada por nuestros
antepasados para defender nuestro país
ucrania es un famoso símbolo de la lucha
por la libertad de ucrania por todo el
ucraniano que rusia ha tratado de
suprimir y destruir completamente
durante 400 años
la un se creó hace casi un ciclo para
luchar contra el dominio soviético en
ucrania durante la segunda guerra
mundial colaboró activamente con los
nazis contra el enemigo común lawes
desde 2014 la aún lucha contra los
separatistas apoyadas por rusia en el
donbass junto con otras organizaciones
nacionalistas como a su propio sector su
participación es el núcleo del mensaje
propagandístico ruso que afirma que
ucrania está en manos de los nazis
segundo lee sólo un puñado de miembros
tienen opiniones extremistas
sanz people
algunas personas están al límite no como
organización sino algunas personas de
esas organizaciones
putin nos llaman nazis pero mi respuesta
sería que no matamos a civiles que
amamos a nuestro país eso nos convierte
en nazis no lo creo
dar un censo
nos llevan a una de las bases de primera
línea de la un al oeste de kiev los
jóvenes reclutas que están siendo
entrenados pronto serán desplegados en
posiciones como esta
esta es una de nuestras posiciones más
importantes están intentando atacar
quiére desde dos direcciones desde el
norte y el oeste y esta es una de ellas
hace dos días estaban 800 metros nuestro
ataque los hizo retroceder en esta
jugada tan dung
con la invasión rusa en marcha la une
está reclutando y haber desplegado más
de 500 combatientes en todo el país